bear asked and this was like a softball
man this is a freaking softball
done pitch yourself to uh to women and
Independence why should they vote for
you and so to the female independent
voter in the suburbs who struggled with
family financing because of inflation
she's now against Biden disapproves of
Biden but wasn't with you in 2020 and so
far is a hard no for you in 2024 but
what do you say to that being at the
right Point what do you say to that
female independent Suburban voter who
feels that way to win her back first of
all I won in 2020 by a lot okay let's
get that straight I won in 2020. you
know and if you look at all of the tapes
if you look at everything that you want
to look at you take a look at truth to
vote where they have people stuffing the
ballot boxes on tapes or Mr President
okay well wait a minute let's go to
recent FBI Twitter let's go to recent
the 51 agents all corrupt stuff
understand about that
collection but that's cheating when they
lost the 22. okay so you got to
understand he's throwing him a softball
here like why should these women who
traditionally women in Independence
uh Suburban women why who have not
traditionally voted Republican and
certainly did not vote for you we know
that why should they come around to you
this time there's a lot of things that
Trump could say Trump could say Hey you
know DeSantis has gone further right
than me on abortion right he wants six
weeks is now what they have in Florida
that seems extreme to me I know that
most women Suburban women especially
middle-class Suburban women don't feel
it like that would have been an honest
answer like so I'm you could say I'm a
little more moderate on that instead he
gave three well he really gave two
issues he said the election was stolen
okay so I don't know what that has to do
with female and independent voters just
going back to your election with stolen
election was stolen election was stolen
okay the base of the base loves that but
not the people that you need to bring
over the new people and also again if
you believe the election was stolen and
I think there's all sorts of reasons
certainly that we should have always
been allowed to talk about it and
there's all sorts of questions that we
should have about it and everything else
the real issue is Donald Trump what have
you done to make sure they will not do
it again and you've done absolutely
nothing that is just the truth so his
answer to what will you do to get middle
class Suburban women to vote for you
right the group that you need more than
anything else his answer was the
election was stolen and look at FBI and
Twitter these things have nothing to do
with nothing the rest of the interview
was a lot of that like it was just bad
trust me I watched it and I was really
trying to find the moments where he was
laying out a vision this is why you
should vote for me this is why I'll do
better than to say this on top of the
fact that he probably created a whole
bunch of legal complications for himself
regarding uh these indictments and
everything else like I cannot imagine if
you're in the midst of these indictments
again even if they're a sham even if
there's an asymmetry all of that stuff
it's like what do you think his lawyers
are saying to him this morning it's very
likely that one of his lawyers will quit
in today because what do you think the
lawyers are trying to put something
together that makes sense here they got
into the classified document stuff he
started talking about how he was he had
mixed his own personal things with the
classified documents like what does that
mean again I'm not Biden did horrible
things with the classified documents and
we need to look at that again I don't
know how many times I can say that sort
of thing but like did Trump have his
baseball glove in with the classified
documents in the sandbox just crazy
[Music]
foreign